dans cette station service de fort de
france les 13 salariés ont bien toucher
la fameuse prime acron cette prime
facultative de 1000 euros maximum
totalement exonérés d'impôts et de
charges étaient là des gestes du
président suite aux mouvements des
gilles et jonah hill à l'entrée du pôle
de ces crimes
donc l'attitude points puis devant donc
il nous a donné une prime de 200 euros
donc voilà on n'a pas à se plaindre
c'est toujours c'est déjà ça comparé à
d'autres stations qui nous propose une
offre innovante
le président a parlé donc je trouve ça
dommage du les sommes que les stations
font banjo dont ils peuvent voir une
forme plus alors qu' à verser cette
prime exceptionnelle selon la cgt m à
peine cinq ou six stations sur une
centaine
le syndicat qui ne désespère pas
d'arracher d'autres accords d'ici la
date limite du 31 mars met en avant la
bonne santé financière du secteur en
2010 est qu'ils ont collecté pour deux
millions quatre cent soixante sept
points 433 euros et 69 centimes au petit
de ce qu'ils appellent la hippie il
s'agit d'un accord secret qui existe
entre les compagnies pétrolières les
gérants avec l'accord de l'état
cette somme ils se partagent ce montant
cette cagnotte entre eux et ce sont les
consommateurs qui pays en faisant du
carburant lorsque les gérants disent
donc ils n'ont pas les moyens ses moyens
existent une station service et une
description de carburant mais c'est
également une boutique qui rapporte au
bo pour la chambre patronale des gérants
la prime macron aurait été bien plus
largement versée n'avons pas tenu des
comptes mais dans les échanges que nous
avons avec les gérants
faut dire qu'il ya un très très grand
nombre de rites gérante ont fait cet
effort à des degrés divers
inamori t on oui je pense
les entreprises qui en ont la capacité
allons très probablement fait mais on ne
peut pas demander à des entreprises et
nous n'avons pas cette capacité à faire
d'ingérence dans les affaires de nous
vendons pour les forcer à aller verser
une prime qui au demeurant n'est pas
obligatoire vis-à-vis des tests les
stations services de l'île représente
plus de 700 salariés
la réalité des chiffres ce sera
certainement délivré par l'état à la fin
de la mesure
en france la prime macro concerne à ce
jour deux millions salariés pour une
moyenne de 450 euros